[Music]
[Applause]
shopping for detergent but it's all
locked
up the tax man and a guy in the alley
want to take my stuff can I keep half
yeah no finally get to my and I
see that's the moment I discover that I
stepped in a human life and that's why
I'm
moving to South
Dakota to a Freer place of doesn't only
view me as a ticket
quot I'm scraping human feces out the
Treads of my
loer I wonder if I would be doing this
if I live down in
Sarasota for South Dakota you need a
thinner stick thank you
Rob I live in a box it cost three grand
a
month with bars on the window so that
people do not steal my
stuff the schools
are my kid can't
read but to be fair to the teachers it
is possible that she can't
see that's why I'm
moving to South
Dakota to a place that isn't me pay
extra taxes on my soda they call it pop
there my bathroom toilets 4T from my St
oh I hear it's better in a bunch of
other places out in
Arizona or South
Dakota as I sang that burst the schools
got worse how I wish that I could pause
it I get this thought each time I'm
robbed and I'm hiding in my claw
it I'm moving I'm moving to South Dakota
California to a place a dozen over tax
and over tiet my
[Music]
toy I just Googled human feces danger
contact disase hold a mile
over it's Times Like These that have
folks finding Freer places they can go
to like South
Dakota or
Sarasota oh